Pete thanks for joining us I read the
column on Josh Rosen what was your what
were your thoughts before you met him
what were your thoughts after you met
him I you know all I heard from four
people around the NFL is that we don't
like this guy and you know the the sort
of wiseacre stuff that he did in college
was you know putting a hot tub in his
room and wearing the anti-trump cap to
play golf at a trump golf course and
just you know he's sort of a wise guy
and and and so I I didn't know what to
think other than because I don't really
follow college football that closely in
the fall and I just start to get to know
who these guys are once February rolls
around so I didn't know him really other
than Pete familes story and si a couple
of years ago which was really good
anyway and I met him and I thought he
was very reasonable
I thought he had good good analyses of
who he is as a person and then the
bottom line in all this is that is that
to me the NFL has an inherent distrust
of rich kids they just do and you have
to prove to them that being rich doesn't
matter
Josh Rosen's family is wealthy his great
grandmother founded the Wharton School
at Penn his father is a very successful
surgeon in Los Angeles they've got a lot
of money so you know so a lot of people
in the NFL just sort of roll their eyes
at that to begin with and I just think
what the best answer he gave me is that
you know having all this money and being
this competitive and being at the
combine and and playing in the pac-12
and everything that should prove to you
that you know how much I love football
and how much I want football I don't
have to work this hard I don't have to
do all this the fact that I'm doing it
and doing it at a high level she proved
to everybody that hey the first time I
get benched I'm not going to quit and go
home and live in the mansion in LA
we love comparisons it feels like any
draft in any sport we like to compare
somebody if you're gonna compare his
personality I guess let's start there is
there a comparison an apt comparison I
was just talking to a coach at the
combine about this you know it kind of
reminds me a little bit of Joe Theismann
which is not the greatest compliment in
the world but here a guy who a guy who
is gonna let you know his opinion on
every on everything in anything and
doesn't mind saying that but having said
that I mean you know I'm not saying you
compare him to Joe's Eisen but his
personality is kind of Theismann ish and
look Dan there's all this stuff about
how a quarterback meshes in the locker
room and you've got to love this guy and
all that stuff and look I've been around
a lot of quarterbacks who are either
quieter guys who are not guys who hate
rally around me guys and all that and
they they when they win the players in
the locker room love them when they play
great the players love them they're not
going out to dinner with each other all
the time the players love him because he
shows up Sunday at 1:00 o'clock and
plays great and all this other stuff
it's all because NFL teams have months
to dig into guys and I don't find this
guy particularly disturbing at all in
any way Peter King the mmq b.com joining
us Dan Patrick show did you have a
stronger opinion on any of these
quarterbacks after leaving the combine
yeah I probably I probably you know just
watching with the most the most
interesting thing about the workouts is
that you can watch all these
quarterbacks throw the exact same route
right in a row so to watch Baker
Mayfield throw the ball you know this
guy's got I'm not saying he's got a I'm
not saying he's got a Noah syndergaard
fastball or anything like that
he's got a really good arm he's from
what I mean I was led to believe yeah
you know average arm you know and all
that I thought his arm was plenty good
at the combine
obviously Josh Allen's got a big arm and
the key for him is going to be
accuracies working with with Jordan
Palmer who has really kind of made a
good name for himself as a guy who can
mentor young quarterbacks and teach them
a lot of great things to do so III think
that I think that the big question now
the biggest question among the
quarterbacks far in a way is going to be
what you think of Josh Allen's ability
to become a 63% passer in the NFL after
being a 56% passer at a mid level
college program Pete thanks for joining
us great stuff on Josh Rosen I enjoyed
it and we'll talk down the road Thank
You sounds good
Peter King mmq be calm and the column is
deciphering Josh Rosen for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]